casey mize against one of the best in
the business well he's pitching with an
enormous amount of confidence he has
stayed on the attack he's using both
sides of the plate he'll have to do that
tonight against the new york yankees the
payoff
and he strikes out la mayhew looking to
start the night
from another 3-2 and he strikes out
stanton as well back-to-back punch-outs
to start this friday night in detroit
for casey mize oh he's going to continue
to attack these guys the 3-1 to right
field mazzara is there and a clean
inning for the most part for casey mize
a couple of strikeouts we head to the
first garrett call making his 11th start
92 strikeouts and 64 and two third
innings
one two
did he go yes he did
missed the spot but uh good grossman
could not hold up
ground ball to second base
oh door two away
candelario turns on one sends it into
the right field corner judge will have
to play it off the wall candelario will
dig for second he's got himself a pop-up
slide two-out double here in the first
grounded short backhanded by torres the
long throw
and they get scoped for the final out
it'll be that second time through the
order that'll test him this one is hit
to deep center field
good room plenty of room one pitch one
out for casey mize
and he swings and misses casey mize has
taken care of dj lemayo not once but
twice
two two to gross right back up the
middle that's a base hit
he just puts together some great at bats
on the ground up the middle and out of
the reach of odor grossman will scamper
all the way to third the tigers have
runners at the corners with only one
away here in the third inning two
runners on and only one out for jamer
candelario who doubled his first time up
a rope to right
rbi single for candelario grossman
scores harold castro all the way to
third and the tigers got something
cooking in the third they're not
intimidated by no stretch of the
imagination they're getting good pitch
to hit and they're not missing them
struck him out
foul tipped it into the glove of jake
rogers and he has punched out giancarlo
stanton twice in his many at-bats mize
is retired eight in a row
grounded fair inside first
kicks off the side wall judge is going
for two and he's in there with a double
that was an excuse me double ball
[Applause]
first pitch swinging slow roller to
short castro's got to hurry and he gets
him at first base a one-out double and
then casey my settles in and gets a
couple of ground balls to his shortstop
tigers over the yankees bottom of the
fourth inning first game of a three-game
set that one is laced into left field
and frazier on the back pedal makes the
play for the second out
[Applause]
swing and a miss
haas down on strikes a bounce back
inning
for coal he retires at tigers in order
top of the fifth inning it's one nothing
tigers and rugnet odor will lead off
here's the o2
swung on and driven a deep right it is
high not as far it is gone to tie the
game
ruge odor lines a pitch into the right
field seats
[Applause]
odor
he homers to right and the ball game is
tied at one
ground it through for a base hit for
frasier
[Applause]
so a home run and a single
3-2 and he struck him out
climbs all the way back and has
higashiyoka shaking his head as he goes
back to the dugout sometimes the hitters
like to slow him down curveball is hit
in the air to left field for a base hit
little inside out swing by gardner
perfect at that time the breaking ball
was up
so he was able to handle it
he got him
wow
blew him away with a 96 mile an hour
four seamer
two away
another 3-2
he sits him down
wow mize gives up the homer then strikes
out the side
al funkhouser takes over on the mound
and the pitch low outside and back back
to the screen three and
two it's sharply in a base hit he got it
through the shift
torres will go to third another hit for
odor first and third
with two odds and that'll bring up clint
frazier
the one-two
on the ground to third tough hop
candelario handles it and gets frazier
at first base
job well done by kyle funkhouser
that's a rope to right
just barreling up keeps serving it up
and he'll keep putting it into the
outfield three for three night for jamer
candelario
and
here's the pitch to cabrera caught on
him missed through it by him at 98. one
away
swing and a miss
tipped into the glove of hikashioka thai
ball game and yet aj hinch goes to
michael former here's the 2-2 swung on
and missed good way to start michael
former's night a punch out in the eighth
i wouldn't be surprised if he goes
inside
[Applause]
got him to roll it over
nice charge from third base and they
barely got her shell up
jammer candelario says
that's a base hit the center field for
glebe taurus
the pitch
lined into right field it's a base hit
three hits for odor moving to second is
labor torres
another 2-2
on the ground to short for harold castro
michael fulmer with a fist pump he
strands two in new york's half of the
eighth and we know he's been aboard once
already tonight here's the 3-1
make it twice for robbie grossman
tonight a leadoff walk in the eighth
there he goes
the throw down to second won't get him
rudder and scoring position grossman
gets himself a really good lead gets a
really good jump he's off and running as
green picks that front foot up and he
steals that base easy
now here's greens 3-1
swung on and line to first lemay who
made the grab so there were two way he
hit that ball as hard as you can hit he
know being on the pitch he was on the
pitch
he's outstanding and extraordinary to
every every position
driven into right center field getting a
good jump as gardner and he runs it down
for the final out
no runs no hits no errors one man left
and and with a pinch hit single boy he's
looked so much better paul
over the last couple weeks no wade who
has all kinds of speed leads off second
and the bit way high it goes back to the
screen
how do y'all like that now that's a wild
pitch
on the wild wild west that's a wild
pitch wade is at third
two two
that was filthy
oh baby
99 away and he waved judge strikes out
soto gets into a jam and works out of it
now the payoff and he walks him to lead
off the ninth
[Applause]
the 2-2
and the dirt
and badou
is out
the ball got away from sanchez but due
straight too far
and sanchez fired a bullet to le mayhew
for the first out
0 for three
high fly ball left field frazier is
there
free baseball bonus cantos coming up so
there is a run or a third but now
there's two out
[Music]
and that will score the go ahead run
judge touches up and the yankees lead
two to one
well you take it any way you can get it
paul
oh what a play by cabrera can't find the
ball
and then he throws in the dirt as odor
will reach
there goes odor the throw from rogers is
on the money to get him
the 1-1
to second base for odor
haas will advance but there are now two
away
well for me chef they've got the right
guy in the batter's box
at the right time it's robbie grossman
who gives you the most consistent at
bats
here's the
payoff fly ball left field frazier going
back measuring it that ball is good
we're going home
on a two-run game winner
robbie grossman delivers the win
that ball had to be bombed because the
wind is blowing out the right field not
the left he got all of it you can't make
this stuff up this is beautiful